Is a chiropractic pillow one of those that sort of has a curve at the bottom. I sleep on my side a lot.
Just make sure if you're sleeping on your side that your spine is straight. Just think of anatomy.
Your spine, you know, looking front to back should be straight. If it isn't, that's called a scoliosis.
If you could look at yourself from the side, you should have a cervical curve of 35 to 45 degrees.
Save what's your thoracic scoy the other way and say what's your lumbar scoy the same one as your cervical spine.
And, you know, if your, if your head is tilted forward, you have a forward head posture, you're going to have a decreased cervical curve.
That's going to cause strain of the sternocleidobascoid, the ski leads, the upper traps and your super sponatus and you know all your sits muscles, your shoulders.
You could have pinched going on in your nerves to your arms, your cervical nerves going down your arms can be an issue.
So massage can help with that as well.
Having somebody help you with your posture, using the tens unit, using ice can help authorizing how the cold can help.
So getting somebody that does more physical work of your body can be helpful going to a physical therapist can be helpful.
That's all.